(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
- Mr. President, Dr. Biden,
Madame Vice President, Mr. Emhoff,
Americans and the world,
when day comes we ask ourselves,
where can we find light in
this never ending shade?
The loss we carry,
a sea we must wade.
We braved the belly of the beast
We've learned that
quiet isn't always peace
and the norms and notions of what just is
isn't always justice.
And yet the dawn is ours
before we knew it.
Somehow we do it,
somehow we weathered and witnessed
a nation that isn't broken,
but simply unfinished.
We the successors of a country and a time
where a skinny black girl
descended from slaves and
raised by a single mother
can dream of becoming president.
Only to find herself reciting for one.
And yes we are far from polished,
far from pristine,
but that doesn't mean
we are striving to form
a union that is perfect.
We are striving to forge
our union with purpose.
To compose a country
committed to all cultures,
colors, characters and conditions of man.
And so we lift our gaze not
to what stands between us,
but what stands before us.
We close the divide because we
know to put our future first
we must first put our differences aside.
We lay down our arms
so we can reach out our
arms to one another.
We seek harm to none and harmony for all.
Let the globe, if nothing
else, say this is true.
That even as we grieved, we grew.
That even as we hurt, we hoped.
That even as we tired, we tried.
That we'll forever be
tied together, victorious.
Not because we will
never again know defeat,
but because we will
never again sow division.
Scripture tells us to envision
that everyone shall sit under
their own vine and fig tree
and no one shall make them afraid.
If we're to live up to our own time
then victory won't lie in the blade
but in all the bridges we've made.
That is the promise to glade,
the hill we climb if only we dare it.
Because being American is
more than a pride we inherit,
it's the past we step
into and how we repair it.
We've seen a force that
would shatter our nation
rather than share it,
would destroy our country if
it meant delaying democracy.
And this effort very nearly succeeded.
But while democracy can
be periodically delayed,
it can never be permanently defeated.
In this truth,
in this faith we trust.
For while we have our eyes on the future,
history has its eyes on us.
This is the era of just redemption
we feared at its inception.
We did not feel prepared to be the heirs
of such a terrifying hour
but within it we found the
power to author a new chapter.
To offer hope and laughter to ourselves.
So while we once we asked,
how could we possibly
prevail over catastrophe?
Now we assert,
how could catastrophe
possibly prevail over us?
We will not march back to what was
but move to what shall be.
A country that is bruised but whole,
benevolent but bold, fierce and free.
We will not be turned around
or interrupted by intimidation
because we know our inaction and inertia
will be the inheritance
of the next generation.
Our blunders become their burdens.
But one thing is certain.
If we merge mercy with might,
and might with right,
then love becomes our legacy
and change, our children's birthright.
So let us leave behind a country
better than the one we were left with.
Every breath from my bronze pounded chest,
we will raise this wounded
world into a wondrous one.
We will rise from the
gold-limbed hills of the West,
we will rise from the windswept Northeast
where our forefathers
first realized revolution.
We will rise from the lake-rimmed cities
of the Midwestern states,
we will rise from the sunbaked South.
We will rebuild, reconcile and recover
and every known nook of our nation
and every corner called our country,
our people diverse and
beautiful will emerge
battered and beautiful.
When day comes we step out of the shade,
aflame and unafraid,
the new dawn blooms as we free it.
For there is always light,
if only we're brave enough to see it.
If only we're brave enough to be it.
- [Man] Woo!
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers lightly)